- [Instructor] The photograph shows author
Helen Keller teaching
actor Charlie Chaplin
the manual alphabet.
So when I read it, I paused a long time
when I saw the semicolon
here because it's there
but it felt strange.
The photograph, and
then it put a semicolon?
The semicolon would separate
two independent clauses.
The photograph for sure is
not an independent clause.
It can't stand on its own as a sentence.
And shows author Helen
Keller teaching actor
Charlie Chaplin the manual alphabet,
that also is not an independent clause.
So I definitely wanna change this thing.
And one thing to think
about, and this is just
a good principle in
general in life, is, well,
do you need this thing or do
you need any punctuation there?
And if you just read
it without punctuation
how does it read?
The photograph shows author
Helen Keller teaching
actor Charlie Chaplin the manual alphabet.
Sounds great, no reason
to put any kind of pause
or anything over there.
The photograph shows.
So I like just no, I like
no punctuation there at all.
Now what are these other choices?
The photograph, colon.
Well, I would use a colon
if I'm about to list
a bunch of things.
You know, there's three
reasons why I liked
this movie, colon, it was entertaining,
there was a lot of action, and
there was a lot of romance.
Or if you were providing
some type of a definition.
But that's not what's going on over here.
And you would typically
have an independent
clause before your
colon, and the photograph
is not an independent clause.
It's not a full, it can't stand on its own
as a sentence.
So rule that out.
And then a dash right over here.
That would be good for a parenthetical.
So the photograph, and
then if you were somehow,
you know, making a little bit like hey,
the photograph, which I lost yesterday,
shows author Keller, author Helen Keller
teaching actor Charlie Chaplin
the manual alphabet,
then you might wanna put
a dash before and after
that parenthetical clause,
that little aside that
you make to the reader.
So I'm gonna rule that one out as well.
And, you know, always go for whatever
is most simple as long as
it actually makes sense.